remember the 90s view a 90s kid you're
gonna prove your credibility by being
alive during a decade you remember that
for the hostel sorry people get really
really excited writing nineties gonna
watch from looper today the real reason
these 90's cartoons were canceled not
the lies we've been told all these years
I'm just Mantid the 1990s were a golden
age of television animation but cartoons
are a business and even the most beloved
show or sometimes canceled to make room
for more profit than maniacs they're
coming back are the rim find a few of
those controversial cartoon
cancellations I never watched that after
debuting on MTV and three kids and
adults watched the two giggling moronic
metalheads of beetus and Butthead
determined which fans were cool in which
sucked that is when they weren't
terrorizing their neighbors teachers and
burger world customers not everybody
liked Beavis and Butthead politicians
called out the show for encouraging
anti-social behavior and one family
blamed Beavis is pyromania for leading
to a deadly house fire nothing stuck
what and beavis and butt-head remainder
[Laughter]
film beavis and butt-head do America
creator Mike judge decided it was time
to end him speaking to Los Angeles
timebreak James bad would not have
actually wanted to stop overhead after
the second season I thought how are we
gonna do this anymore
I was completely burned out judge wound
up sticking around for seven seasons and
season burned out by water tower on the
Warner Brothers movie lot Animaniacs was
a cartoon quickly embraced by both
children and adult audiences alike
debuting in 1980 Animaniacs satirized
cartoon tropes while being completely
self-aware offering up innuendo laced
dialogue and biting social commentary
among the kid-friendly laughs
Animaniacs ran for five seasons and spun
off its most popular side characters
Pinky and the brain but pop hits WB
ended the show and
ninety-eight according to creative Jim
Gray and due to a business decision
regarding another much cheaper kit show
a Japanese anime series with massive
commercial potential
Ruger explained Kids WB was handed
Pokemon for free on a home theaters so
then they wanted everything for it all
Animaniacs cost warner brothers too much
money to make and promote so off it went
at first glance top a Marlins animated
spawn series looked like a show for kids
but spawn was based off of McFarland's
top-selling comic series an extremely
dark violent story about a former
assassin who gets killed by his boss
sent to hell and ends up working for
Satan our material
[Music]
spawn ran for three seasons on HBO and
won an Emmy Orion Spain an animated
program the show's third season was a
bust
HBO no HBO HBO now sheen division was
withering on the vine after enduring
numerous production difficulties the
show earned a quiet cancellation in 1999
that's just animation and comic book
adaptation moody quiet and literally
dark it demonstrated to bring this show
back it for traumatic superhero content
could appeal to children and adults this
Batman was so highly regarded that Fox
aired the show in prime time for a while
and really I don't know hey kids to
supplant Azam's Tempe is voice actor
Kevin Conroy even tops many lists of the
best Batman actors however in 1995 after
three years and 85 episodes the series
left the air according to Conroy even
though the audience was still invested
and the actors were willing to continue
the creator's had run out of ideas and
wanted to end the show on a high note
they're out of copper he didn't want to
compromise on the quality of what
they've had and start creating kind of
silly stories fortunately for Batman
fans the story ideas didn't dry up for
long a sequel series to the beloved show
debuted a couple years after its
cancellation bringing back most of the
animated series cast and crew in
factories of my manner all new Batman
adventures debuted on kids W back in
September of 1997 Oh originally created
by a mystic was an animated sitcom about
a snobby hapless New York City movie
reviewer named Jay Sherman he hates most
movies Aziz tries to raise his son as
fast as he can was it in the Samson
wacky family yeah I think he loved the
show to fire his voice of Jay we did it
for ABC and ABC goes we love it and then
they cancelled it after seven shows
following its debut season insulation
The Critic moved over to Fox and aired
immediately after The Simpsons where
creators Al Jean and Mike
had previously worked as writers and
showrunners according to Lovitz The
Critic brought in excellent ratings for
Fox retaining 90% of the huge audience
and yet in 1994 Fox pulled the plug
despite a solid performance an executive
at the network thought the 8:30 p.m.
Sunday timeslot could be better used by
a new show gene explained the guy who
ran the network then John metoya just
didn't like the show he preferred to
show that no one remembers called House
of buggin with John Leguizamo lineup of
silly cartoons and wacky adventures this
contemplative and sometimes violent show
is stylistically different from its
Disney Afternoon predecessors like goof
troop salesman and ducktales submarine
tone an approach to Batman the Animated
Series garbage concerns the day-to-day
activities of magical beings who protect
New York City at night the characters
were architectural gargoyles by day
imbued with the spirits of 1000 year old
Scottish folk creatures gargoyles I have
the dictators in 78 episodes but was
ultimately cancelled because it wasn't a
mega hit according to the creator Greg
Weisman it didn't perform up to
expectations Disney really wanted it to
outdo Mighty Morphin Power Rangers and
it failed to succeed it's not bigger
than Mighty Morphin my 2001 foresee
every scene angry information seemed
imminent according to their creator
editor I have a follow me I've done a
scene behind schedule and had generally
worn out or welcome mother izing that
the end was near Paciorek and the rest
of the angry beavers staff decided to go
out on a blaze of glory Kocurek
and show staff writer Roger ash Fokker
wrote a script for a series finale
episode called bye-bye beavers an
installment equal parts dark and meta
dagon nor become to realize that they
are not real but cartoons and that their
show is about to be canceled which means
they will cease to exist
at first nickelodeon signed off on the
stress here when executives noticed all
the jokes making fun of nickelodeon they
reversed course according to writer
Michael Wright they so many other and
said wait this makes us look bad
they killed a recording of the show
Swiss actors reading it yes Oh 2006 by
1995 everything with original
programming and one of its first new
shows was a low-budget animated series
with largely improvised dialogue called
dr. Katz professional therapist doc does
it bother you want to touch your face
like this
a little bit inappropriate you know
probably for me to hold my hand their
clients were all stand-up comedians who
lay on his couch and relate neuroses
that were really just bits from their
stage routines he also had a lazy how
interested then and attempted to have a
social life ironically its dr. Katz own
success that led to its demise the show
helped put Comedy Central on the TV map
showing that the channel had a unique
sensibility and was a home for anything
we should do other that years after its
debut South Park premiered on Comedy
Central and became a monster hit house
Cecily ray email viewers
dr. Katz attracted an older audience and
since it wasn't in the demographic that
the now service network was trying to
lure it got canceled strange with the
arrival of child friendly cable networks
like Nickelodeon and the popularity of
syndicated shows the ratings for once
beloved Saturday morning cartoons
started to slip
NBC president Brandon Tartikoff analyzed
the budget Everage Saturday morning
cartoon cost $300,000 to produce
Tartikoff and his team realized that it
would be much cheaper to get rid of the
cartoons in favor of new shows or sports
in 1991 NBC signed a long-term contract
with Notre Dame to air the college's
games on Saturday mornings they cost the
network about 1 million dollars a game
which was still cheaper than programming
six hours of cartoons every week plus it
could charge higher advertising rates
for football than it could for kid stuff
in 1992 and a block of low-budget sitcom
Saved by the Bell and eliminating the
entire 1991 to 1992 Saturday morning
cartoon at stir-crazy
check out one of our newest videos right
here long story short coming soon money
Oh cancel was hey I like the inclination
of some of them kind of like beavis and
butt-head and batman the animated series
of we also cancelled because we just
felt that our best times were behind us
and that we don't want to diminish and
quality said what we need to say but
majority of these were hey we're not
making enough we want to make more we
want to say is we want to charge more
for ads we want to pay nothing for
production it's pretty nuts to hear some
of the history though to think of NBC
shifted completely away from animation
on the Saturday morning cartoons for
football game and live-action channel
excited by the bell those blocks it just
seems so jarring and I'm surprised
panned out for them yeah it just takes
us a drastic [ __ ] like that that anyone
would supplement it with a kids show or
an animated thing it was just a football
shift or the news or something and it's
funny to me because like that was the
bane of my existence back in the day
when I would come home on a weekday and
they wouldn't be playing The Simpsons
because of baseball but like Saturday
morning I guess we're about to find out
in the comments or whatever but like
who's up Saturday morning like calling
up football first thing in the a.m. and
I think this is a strong list because it
is titled popular 90s cartoons and these
are pretty and easy yeah these are
popular I'm surprised we're not bringing
him the viewership because you know when
you're a kid you're not really thinking
about viewership and stuff like that
gargoyles quite a influential monumental
series or its time and I think it's
still a pretty damn good show I would
say it's on par with Batman the Animated
Series well that gets brought up every
few years as like shows you ought to
revisit the reasoning for cancellation
on gargoyles oh well we wanted to have
perform Mighty Morphin Power and you're
like so what so get yourself a Power
Rangers like damn can you imagine this
mentality today I mean I'm sure it still
exists in the comparison numbers but the
amount of TV shows or are now I mean
before there was like a few cable shows
or is like primarily network television
acts
and now with streaming the abundance of
shows on cable channels there are so
many shows and it's like every computers
keep making it this was kind of
fascinating to me because they had a
range of cartoons from children's level
to more adult-oriented animation and
there's one thing that we talk about
here and there is the animation that's
not aimed at kids or at least
incorporates kids isn't as served nish
here and it's funny to me cus like half
the shows on this list we're more adult
pitch shows like dr. Katz of The Critic
or a spawn yeah and it's funny to me to
look back you know note that at least a
few of these shows did have you know a
more adult sensibility and maybe that's
also probably why they weren't able to
raise as much money like gargoyles you
had the kids and whatnot but for the
stuff that was aimed at older audiences
I would imagine I guess that unless
you're getting you know the younger
20-somethings you know like they said
dr. Katz wasn't as popular or something
like South Park and I'm like yeah I
gotta can see that it sounds like
something you'd put like late at night
on Adult Swim now it's just such an
ironic conclusion for dr. Katz we were
able to determine that we have an
audience here at a special niche market
for adult oriented comedy and animation
format and then it's sponsz South Park
and that leads to being canceled but so
like that was kind of my concern of what
would happen when Family Guy came back
with it's insane popularity and if it
would wipe out the Simpsons if they were
like well Family Guy is just way more
popular now and so we should cancel
because like it seems like with the
discussion with The Simpsons too has
been quite frequently like we're kind of
always concerned that we might not get
revived here you know yeah yeah and
still going strong Family Guy is an
interesting subject to bring up I think
because a big part of what brought
Family Guy back as that show was
canceled what's the DVD sales the studio
solid we're making a lot of money off of
these DVD sales and there seems to be a
big fan base for it now so it makes me
wonder if some of these shows that were
canceled if they did have their DVD
releases at that like close to the time
of cancellation and if they saw an
uptick in sales and then maybe further
expansion of the fan base
post cancellation if something like
gargoyles might have come back
the air because we are in this weird day
and age where we do burn 5-series
sometimes really fast like Brooklyn
nine-nine I remember that was canceled
and then like a couple days later who
was picked up on a different network
it's such a strange time to live him but
it's it's weird to think of how some of
these shows might have been saved today
and if they were canceled now for weird
reasons and then if they got saved on
some other platform Animaniacs that was
one of my favorite shows growing up
Pinky and the brain was more my jam but
I definitely watched both those series
know they're bringing back Animaniacs
those of course there's a little bit of
trepidation but I feel like I feel like
peaking the brain would be more
challenging to make work whereas
Animaniacs worked off of it's topical
commentary of this climate that it was
living in and so I feel like they could
do something with it today and perhaps
even make it a little bit more mature
since it did have a little bit of its
irreverence and meta qualities yeah it
is even more popular nowadays and if I
recall correctly like you could even
learn a thing or two watching like
Animaniacs are especially hysteria and
so like I think especially shows like
that that have some kind of not to be
boring but in educational benefit are
more worth keeping on hand which is why
like something like Animaniacs is like
as a bummer that you yeah I gave it the
act and I'm in it opting for then
bringing and we're hearing rumors of
x-men possibly coming back the animated
series or they're starting a brand new
one Batman the Animated Series is one
I've been opting for like they should
try bring that back I mean if the
creators the ones who held that series
really don't feel like they have
anything left in the tank for that show
yes so I just think that but the
animation quality that it had back then
how great it would prompt it look even
more striking today there's tons of
Batman stories that continuously pull
from Kevin Conroy Mark Hamill still
voiced Joker in Batman you know on a lot
of different shows and adaptations video
games they're still in the game so I
think that Batman the Animated Series
would be a wonderful revival and
especially for like HBO max-width though
strange reception that streaming service
has been happy yeah yeah I imagine if I
went through the comments on this it
would be gargoyles and Batman the anime
Emperor like beavis and butt-head did my
church kid and I never finished king of
the hill that
have a ending yeah oh yeah I believe it
did I mean that kind of just is a
testament to my judges great writing
ability that even if his heart's not in
it still to such a great yeah and that's
the thing is like I mean if beavis and
butt-head ran for seven seasons and king
of the hill ran for fourteen yeah he and
his writing staff and at least I haven't
seen a ton of beavis and butthead
comprehensively but king of the hill at
least in my eyes managed to maintain a
very consistent tone of voice and a
pretty consistent quality over its life
and they said that thing that the
Simpsons guys have said where it was
basically like every season we thought
it was the end and then they just kind
of kept renewing us yeah until the
Cleveland Show came props to Mike judge
cuz like that he's the he's so busy he
makes so much stuff you know some makes
a lot of shows yeah is that like three
successful TV shows it's pretty crazy
man movies um three successful in a
podcast every successful play yes
alright guys well what is your favorite
90s animated show leave your thoughts
down below subscribe and looper if you
haven't done so already subscribe for
the real rejects click that notification
about last but not least gene Jeter
wanted to shout out our homeboy here who
lives in the East Coast I believe in New
York right now
don't touch her face it's very scary
over there like an all of America New
York's definitely got it the worst gene
is doing his best to keep up the
positive vibes and the positive attitude
he is staying very safe and on his
channel he put together a nearly
hour-long video but it's music it's
music to quarantine and chill part 2
gave it a listen while I was writing
some messages probably listening like
half of it and honestly it wasn't very
relaxing to help calm down my thoughts
my brain waves quite a delight so guys
if you're looking for a great
quarantined chilled set list to listen
to I highly recommend gene Jeter's video
there's a link in the description box
thank you so much gene for putting this
together and in the midst of this
pandemic in the midst of you living on
the East Coast where it's really nuts
I'm so happy to know that there's
someone over there who's doing their
best to keep the positive vibes alive
thank you for being you love you gene